this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
what's happening you bad [__]
the joint is brought to you by
on it listen to me
black label
is back in stock
you know i'll tell you what else is back
in stock the little shots alpha brain
tremendous the black labor alpha brain
is great new mood is great they're still
killing the game on it and that's why
i've been with them for 12 [__] years
now do me a favor if you're looking for
supplements that work
start with on it.com
especially alpha brain they're the only
company that if you don't like alpha
brain you're not happy with alpha brain
they'll give you your money back and
they don't even want the product back
who believes in the product that much
on it so go to hana.com right now
press and code joey joint with church
and get 10 off any supplement delivered
right to your house the joint is also
brought to you by listen draftkings an
epic nfl season comes to an end this
[__] sunday and draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner the super bowl 56 has an offer
for new customers i'm not going to tell
you again this is a great deal guys you
get 56 to one odds which means if you
bet five owls on on either the
cincinnati bengals or
the los angeles rams and your team comes
in you win 280 in free bets i don't know
if you've gambled before but this is
your [__] week and uncle joey's
gonna
guide you download the draftking
sportsbook app
and let's get this [__] party
started
use
promo code joey now if the super bowl
aim for you i don't know if you remember
what's on sunday night it's ufc 271
direct from [__] h town the big man
against the [__] tosa super will he
drunk will he drink out of his shoe or
will [__] the
the maniac win throw down on who in each
fight and how the fights will finish and
much much more listen fists are sure to
fly in the main event with izzy and the
australian so don't miss out like i said
before download the draftking sports
book app bet 5 000 or more on the super
bowl 56
and get 280 and free bets that's promo
code joey at draftkings sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of super
bowl 56. now you got to be 21 or older
minimum age and location requirements
vary by jurisdiction see
draftkings.com
for full list of requirements and state
specific responsible gaming resources
voidward prohibited now if you've got a
gammon problem call one eight hundred
gambler if you're in tennessee call
1-800-889-9789 if you're in connecticut
789-7777
and if you're in new york eight seven
seven eight hope and y
but if you don't have a gammon problem
let's download the draftking sportsbook
app today and put your betting on the
super bowl ufc
college basketball and much much more
casino
and new york were ready to rock use code
joey the joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion listen to me i'm about to turn
59 i got pains and [__] that you never
even [__] dreamed of but cbd lion is
there start with the tincture
start with the tincture and get back to
me after two months and tell me you
don't feel better it's gonna take a
while to get started but if you have
shoulder pain knee pain muscular pain
they got a tremendous cream they got a
bad ball
they got kinesiology tape
they got gummies with melatonin and a
cbd lion is number one in my book if you
want a nice little cbd present for
yourself
go to cbdline.com read up on the third
party lab results if you see something
you fo you like or something might work
for you voila
put in code joey joint or church and get
20 off delivered to your house with cbd
lion as far as i'm concerned the best
cbd line in the business now
without further ado let's get this
[__] party started we got a lot
to talk about it's february night
[__]
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
we're back for another fun-filled
[__] episode with uncle joey on
wednesday
february the 9th
super bowl weekend [__] people are
losing their minds nobody knows who to
bet
the line went back up to four and a half
the who gives a [__] i'm just looking to
have a great time win a little [__]
doe you know maybe uh
cleveland and the under i don't [__]
know i don't know how to [__] cincinnati
in the under i don't [__] know but
i'm excited
uh valentine's week the whole [__]
deal you know you should be [__]
excited too trim up get your [__]
girl card
some [__] disgusting chocolate
because that chocolate is [__]
disgusting when you really look at it
you eat that [__] i just got a cbs thing
that said you know you got like 15 15
off on one of those chocolate hearts and
i'm like dog
i mean when i used to eat those
[__] by the dozen now
you taste the chocolate and it tastes
[__] old now to me but anyway who
gives a frenchman's [__]
uh let's get the elephant out of the
[__] room you know i'm saying all
week people want to hear from me
what do i know you know i don't know
nothing
i don't know nothing rogue is my brother
that's all i know is he racist no i'm
cuban slashed african which makes me
half [__] black on some [__]
levels and i've never read it from him
my other buddies are jewish a bunch of
you know listen rogan's not racist and
that's where it ends right there [__] it
who gives a [__] if he is you know what
i'm saying you people are always uh well
not you people not the [__] joint
people you know i love you [__]
with all my heart but lately it's just
been uh a weird world and that's like i
was telling my sister let me tell you
something guys
did you [__] think
when we used to get together
in 2010
in 2011
and we were doing those podcasts
especially one that i'm in i'm sitting
there high as a kite looking at the
[__] ceiling and then people like oh
you got off camera no i didn't i dropped
a butterweed on the [__] floor you
know what i'm saying you gotta look for
that [__] it was in my hand and
it rolled out when i was all [__]
high looking up but anyway i'm not
making excuses for anybody but what i'm
trying to say is
if you find any podcast from 2010
whether it's joe
whether it's myself
whether it's bird christian whether it's
you're gonna hear some things
that are gonna bother you
because nobody knew
these podcasts were gonna get big
nobody had a [__] idea
that these podcasts were going to branch
out
into you know mainstream entertainment
we were just doing it to talk [__] to
see where it would go and then it got a
little serious and after a while we
started cleaning up our act me
i'm not racist but i say a ton of racist
[__] you guys know that i'm not racist
at all and i'll tell you something
there's times i said [__] on the podcast
and that weekend i've gone on the road
you know i'll say something about hindus
or something about the brothers myself
or something about chinese people when i
get to a show i'll see like three
chinese people and the whole 10 second
walk to them is what are they going to
say to me you know for insulting them or
whatever not once
not once has any race come up to me and
said hey man i dig what you say on the
podcast except when you talk about
hindus or arabs or hummus so everybody
understands that when i talk i talk from
love always remember it's not what you
say
it's how you say it even on the rogan
[__] thing when he kept saying the
n-word when he kept saying it over and
over again you didn't know he you know
you could see
if he was using it against somebody or
he was hurting somebody's feelings but
you could tell you could just tell
that's why they deleted everything that
led up to that so
listen guys it's so weird the
assumptions that people make
you know i told you guys about a year
ago a friend of mine sent me like six
pages of emails
that he had gotten from some [__] uh
one of those
chats
about the conspiracies on why rogan and
i
left to hollywood
ready did you see that one about that
there was a rape at the comedy store now
guys i had never even
heard of the [__] when my buddy sent me
this i was like oh my god
this is so [__] bad and listen i
wasn't mad at anybody
i never attacked anybody i never came on
here and said [__] you for saying those
things
what i said as i was reading it was i
feel bad
i feel bad that
when we started doing this it was just a
[__] joke it was just something to
pass time
we didn't know it was going to turn into
something now
it's like people are making
uh just the wrong
narrative
people are creating the wrong
you know not assumptions but they're
just giving us a background that we
never knew we had like i never knew why
that there was a bunch of rape girls at
the comedy store that were looking to
pressure i didn't i've never even heard
of that i was a member of the comedy
store for 23 [__] years so
you know people gonna say [__] you take
whatever but again when i read those
pages those three pages four pages i
felt bad for people
i really did in my heart i was like man
this is what they wrap their heads
around all day long
is somebody they don't know like i
haven't done that since i was like 10.
you know what i'm saying when you're a
fan of a band or something you're like
oh i wonder how he's feeling you know
it's like when uh singers dog did you
see a
what the what's the [__] movie oh uh
the movie with marky warburg with
jennifer aniston when he joins the
[__] band that the guy was gay and he
fills in for the singers like a judas
priest rip off
or whatever i forgot what i was going to
say my marquee
rockstar yeah yeah that's a that's a
great [__] movie
but in rockstar there was like uh i
forgot what i was gonna
make a point
about the dog
who the [__] knows you know i'm just
thinking that
it has to change at some [__] levels
you know we when we were starting the
podcast
i still get
you're not gonna believe this guys
i said this was
i
said this story in august
of 2010
and then we did a show felicia and i
were beauty and the beast 10 10 2010
and that's the first time i realized i
could sell tickets you know it's so
[__] weird
for years i did law not svu
the longest yard analyzed that you know
i did so many things uh
you know my name is earl and i'm just
telling you these from
when i would do comedy shows people come
up to me after the show this is way
before the podcast and go hey we enjoyed
you in the long as you are do we like
you and santa and uh spider-man 2 or
we light you and [__] my name is earl
so we came down tonight but that would
be
four people like if i did five shows and
a weekend in some place
i'd get like 10 people who said they saw
me on this
or they saw me on that but it never
really brought people in
i was
you know when i got out of comedy in
2008 and a half i gave it like a
three or four month break
i was done because
nothing i could do could make me sell
tickets my material wasn't catchy enough
i wasn't cool or hip you know what i'm
saying i didn't have like a hat or an
earring or a goatee you know to
you know always have like a hoodie on
like i'm cold even though it's 90
degrees you know or me smoking a
cigarette taking a picture with a
cigarette i was never that cool guy
so i didn't have a hook people wouldn't
come see me it was just that
so
when i got out of stand up i had been
doing stand-up already like not got out
of it when i just gave it a breather
to think about what i was gonna do next
i had gotten married
and i was living in the valley i lived
around the corner from a [__] car
dealer
my wife was working she was starting to
make money and i'm like what do i want
to keep doing
i could go on the road with rogan i
could do this i could do that i just
wanted to cover my ass i wasn't looking
to get rich i just wanted to be happy
and see what the [__] was available to
me
and you know we would go on the road i
would go on the road with rogan and
redband these [__]
would do these weird podcasts at night
and i didn't know listen nobody knew
where these things were going to end up
nobody you know it's like
saturday live hired shane gillis and
they found the podcast in 2012 when he
said some
asian derogative word or whatever i have
no idea what he said i never knew shane
gillis was i know he's a nice [__]
guy from what i heard ari loves him but
i never even knew who shane was pardon
me because i was in la i didn't know him
as a new york [__] comic
or anything
he said something on a podcast again
i'm sure all these guys when we started
podcasting
we just didn't know
we were stoned i mean i was just [__]
stoned i was
in the heat of it in la between the
wheat stores
and we didn't [__] know i didn't know
what the podcast was going to lead to
where it was going to go nobody did
nobody [__] did you know and now we
have a million [__] podcast but back
to the story
i didn't know
what to do about
not selling tickets i had no [__]
idea
and one of the things that i still get i
swear to god guys
10 12 years later
once a week
somebody's
sends an email to my [__] uh
messenger or
something and it's hate mail about the
story of us uh
you know taking the hooker's wig and
lighting it on fire i mean
people will [__] still be hard at
that that's a couple stories i've told
that people i i was like people are
never gonna forgive me for this story
but they moved on with it they knew it
was me back then the same thing as the
hooker story this is me back then if you
guys
listen to anything about me i'm not a
big hooker guy
i'm not a big i'm not i'm not you know
listen i went to the 10 40 club one time
the girls [__] scared the [__] out of
me i'm scared of vd
i went to a clinic one time when i was a
kid with a friend of mine he had some
type of [__] coming out of his dick and
i just went for moral support whatever
the [__] you call that [__] and while
we're sitting there at the [__] vd
clinic some guy came out with like
[__] herpes
guys i don't know what it was i don't
want don't throw me to the [__]
gay wolves i don't know what it was in
fact
i don't even know if this guy was gay
let's just leave it at that he he looked
a little weird he looked a little
peculiar
his skin didn't look well
and he had like a rash around his mouth
and i remember he was just sitting there
with this rash and i'm sitting with my
buddy and i'm thinking about the vd and
his dick and i'm thinking about all
these other people got venereal diseases
and i'm like you know what
i like [__] and i like titties and [__]
but they were getting a venereal disease
like i can't even imagine
coming in here to a doctor and tell them
i got [__]
you know uh custard coming out of my
dick i can't even [__] imagine you
know i can't even imagine what it smells
like i can't even imagine what it feels
and then years later when i got to
comedy i i fingered an indian girl up in
uh
the dakotas somewhere no no idaho i was
dancing with some american indian girl
and we were dancing up close and tight
my finger and i smelled something funky
in the air and she had a yeast infection
i didn't know if i got home but that's a
complete different [__] time but all
those stories
have led to me and all those disgusting
puerto rican nelson stories when we were
kids we'd sit around and listen to him
talk and at the end of all those stories
it was always how he had gotten vd or he
had gotten crabs or he had gotten
syphilis so from listening to all that
as a kid it went into my psyche
and i just immediately did not like
that whole world
to this day i'm not into that whole
world listen i i love a woman's body
just like the [__] next guy
but
it makes me feel creepy to go to a
[__] strip club
especially now at my age i go to a strip
club people like joey what are you a
[__] dirty old man yeah but not
really like i'm not a dirty old man
i don't look at other women like that
anymore i know what i have to offer
which is
zelch my dick works on a 50 basis i got
to drop a blue chew on it to make a
[__] stick you know what i'm saying
so i'm not going to waste anybody's time
and i'm not going to go through the
embarrassment of going through his trip
i didn't dig strip clubs and i was young
i did
i like strip clubs but i want to do
everything you know what i'm saying when
i go to strip club if you come with
pasties on your tits what am i 13. do i
got a hat with a propeller on my [__]
head what do i need this for i want to
see everything i want to see [__] shots
clits if you could smoke a cigarette
with your [__] i'll throw you the small
fin or the ten dollars you know i'm into
all that craziness but that doesn't
happen no more if you did go to one of
those like if i went into one of those
places when we had to wear a mask
there's that's it it's over there's no
more [__] mask it's over march 7th in
jersey the kids don't have to wear masks
no more it's over
but you know i was never into any of
that [__]
like my wife says she goes you're the
dirtiest talking prude
i've ever met in my life my wife always
says to me you're just a dirty talking
[__] prude you know and you talk
dirty to over
compensate for your [__] prudence i'm
not really a prude i just don't want to
see a lot of [__] you know i'm not a
playboy bunny type of guy even though i
like [__] i'm not a porno type of guy i
like [__] i you know listen i'm not
i'm whatever the [__] you call i love
[__] but that was never my thing you
know and uh
i as a kid i guess you know i want an
experiment with a hooker at least one
time you know when you're a kid you hear
all these [__] stories from your from
older kids and you're like you know
they'll tell you they got a hooker in
vegas or something you're like ah that
sounds like something i want to do until
i did it
when i [__] did that [__] it was not
enjoyable to me it was uh to me it was a
horrible experience you know i remember
going into spanish harlem one time or as
they call it the barrio with a buddy of
mine two buddies of mine we went to cop
and we were going to cop but we didn't
want him to know we're going to cop
we could cop without him knowing that we
were doing drugs this kid was
straightening us he just drove over the
city and i'll never forget we were
walking up the stairs
and he goes again why are we in this
[__] building in harlem
and like because we're gonna [__] some
women all right he looked at me goes
what
make love to a strange woman
and that's how i felt like it was all
fun and games until i was at the 10 40
club and the girl walked up to me and
had to grab my friends like take her and
i'll never forget like yeah i was hot
and sticky until we walked into the back
and she took her stockings off and then
i saw the stab wounds the tattoos
the [__] cuts the burn marks
it was [__] horrible and as much as i
was a man i want to get that [__] i
wanted to run out of there
with all my [__] heart guys
and she sat me down you know i had
already paid and she talked me into it i
felt like [__] crying but what was i
gonna do i was already there she got on
top of me and when she started moving
her hips i had never had a girl be on
top of me i'm not gonna lie nobody that
alone put me in a [__] state of
confusion but when she started moving
the hips i had a condom on and i could
feel my dick against her [__] going
and every time i heard
i got a little bit more sick in my
stomach i was like
i'm like what the [__] when is this
gonna end
i didn't know anything about coming
early i didn't know about premature
ejaculation i didn't know none of that
[__] i was just a young [__] kid and
then she stopped in the middle
and i'm like focusing on god i'm like
please you know don't [__] send me to
hell because i was still catholic back
then well i was on the borderline back
then and [__]
next you know she stops and she goes for
an extra ten dollars you could eat my
[__] guys
i didn't know what to do i was like what
and i just threw the [__] off me and
guys
i was never so embarrassed those four
guys that took me the three other guys i
went i remember for days i was telling
them at the school don't say no to
nobody about that that's a horrible
experience all my friends found that but
eventually it blew over but i always
kept it close to my [__] heart i
don't ever want to be with a [__]
hooker i don't like talking to him
nothing i mean listen if they talk to me
in a casino it's always a blast i think
the last casino i stayed out in vegas
not uh
not that tropican not the not treasure
island
and not where i used to work at south
point
but one of the hotels i want last time i
was there for the ufc i was with joe
and i remember leaving at 5 30 in the
morning from the hotel and what i saw
was [__] it was like land of the
living dead for hookers they were all
over the place half of them have been
shot their skirts were [__] messy it
was just ugly and i'm
and they're looking for a date and i'm
out there going who the [__]
would take one of these women up to that
bed i mean again i got nothing against
women i got none against dirty women you
know i love you at all my heart a girl
with a little dirt on her heels never
killed nobody i'm all in
but that magnitude of [__] has always
turned me the [__] off when a woman's
got a magnet through the [__] in it i
got to move the [__] on it's never been
for me so when i was a kid i that said i
was done when i was 17 i knew i didn't
want to be with a hooker i was going to
save myself for the right [__] girl
hold on one second
every once in a while i feel something
in there i hate [__] nose in my ass
thank god
oh my god i just
i just hit a snot on the side of the
wall this
welcome to the manscape [__]
weed whacker tremendous oh
i love it
it smells funny too i hate them when it
has a little wang like i was trimming my
[__] with something like that it does
have a little wang through it so i hated
all that [__] now i had friends that
were [__] animals i had one friend in
particular who
god rest her soul
i [__] missed this [__] you
know
i mean without even knowing the other
day i was doing something
and i had to put the date on a piece of
paper for something and i looked at the
paper a little later on i'm like [__]
it's
2022.
like every once in a while you just
repeat the numbers you know every day i
repeat the date to confirm it in my head
i'm like it's 2 000 [__] 22. holy
[__]
i did the [__] math
i don't know if you guys know this or
not i just remembered it i don't think
you guys know it because if i just
[__] remembered it
this is 40 years
from me graduating high school this year
which in reality i never really
graduated high school
i was a couple credits short but
it's 40
[__] years guys and i know half years
i've been out of high school
for maybe 10 or 15 years you don't even
think about it well the first time you
think about high school
it's ten years after you get out of
there
like one day just dawn's on you one of
your friends call you you're going to
the 10-year reunion you're like what
what the [__] are you talking about
10-year oh my god it has been [__] 10
years obviously
nobody [__] called me for the 10-year
reunion in 92. i was off the [__]
ropes
uh then i was back here in 93
and people like you didn't go to a
10-year reunion nobody told me about it
and i wouldn't have come anyway i was
never really a big uh
you know
guy into that [__]
then that 20-year reunion for me would
have been 2002 and i was like wow
the thing that saved me was i booked the
longest yard in 2004 and i'm like all
right now i can go to the reunion
because nobody wants to go to their
reunion of [__] loser especially 20
years and everybody goes there flashing
it's like the night after they robbed
the [__] thing on goodfellas remember
morty everybody's got that good clothes
on and [__] yeah you got your good
clothes on you got your jewelry on
you know so
i
i somebody mentioned
the 20th anniversary to me but i
by that time i was in
l.a i was rocking and rolling you know
not rocking and rolling but i was
on the move i was established and i was
[__] hitting it as hard as i could
for the 30 [__] year anniversary yeah
i don't even remember the 30th
anniversary all the 25.
i just basically remember [__] uh
just the 40th anniversary of my high
school and i'm going to tell you
something
if i go back to february 9th
of 80 [__] 2 82 just saying
makes me feel [__] old and you know
you think 82. yeah that just happened a
couple years ago no it didn't joey it
was 40 [__] years ago
40 [__] years ago do you know what i
was doing
40 years ago at that time not sitting in
front of a camera with white [__]
hair talking about my life i'd tell you
that much i was out by this time i
quit high school
i was done with high school
i had taken uh
mass back century
to court because uh we're not really
caught like we fought him it was a union
thing
so massback century was paying me
[__] huge doe not to go to work here
i am 18 [__] years old
and i'm collecting money from [__]
mass back century but here's what gets
better i was also collecting
unemployment because i didn't give a
[__]
people like you're gonna get caught
they're gonna catch you and make you pay
it back these [__] were paying me 450
[__] dollars
or 400 a week and they would give you
cash
that's when you went unemployment and
right then and there you signed your
check and they gave you a little
envelope with [__] cash i was getting
600 i was getting whatever the [__] i
was getting 400 a week
that's 1600 a month i was probably
picking up
two or three thousand a month from
mazbag hardware century and i was
hustling with three [__] legs do you
understand me
i'm gonna forget like i was quiet that
year i was living with the runnies
and every day like i refuse to go to
[__] work mr ronnie would be furious
like you guys got to get jobs like what
uh
we're not doing nothing we're hustling
i'm paying rent
we're [__] hustling what do you want
from us you know what i'm saying
and for some reason i was always friends
with a kid named roger licensed grammar
school
and he
we started hanging out like uh maybe
october of 81
and we also had this kid fernie
that uh i love with all my heart he's
still alive and kicking but
he won't talk to any of us he's gone i
went on his facebook page the other day
and i couldn't when i realized
that in 40 years you know i went on his
facebook page
just to see how he was doing he's still
posting pictures up a marilyn monroe
every [__] day that's all he posts a
new picture of marilyn monroe every day
with one of her sayings it's not good
he's got hiv he's not right but
he was my best friend i love him i
always love him i always have a place on
my table
if he comes in then there's my man
stinky my man glenn i saw him a few i
saw him for dinner twice we have gone
out for dinner twice
since i've been here but
we were a [__] team
and at that point
we bri we were breathing for one another
i don't know if you guys know what that
means that means that one of us don't
have it the other one did and there's
there's no [__] tab
i had found my little [__] three
buddies and we were tighter than [__]
i lived with mike ronnie and i was tight
with him i was tight with this kid
rhaego who's also gone i was tight with
the birkels i was tight with like 20
[__] dudes but
my
immediate [__] hangout crew the four
dudes i hung out with listen
we started a [__] reign of terror
that january and it didn't stop it
didn't end
until probably 80 [__] fall like we
were just
on a tear we were inseparable
and it all started with that
period of us every other week
i was bumping into his camp i guys
it's from
delivering refrigerators i got there one
day and there was [__] 20 air
conditioners and i stole every single
one of them
to robin a pool you know one of those
[__] public pools when they have
hamburgers and [__] in there we robbed
all that stuff i mean that summer
i had kids that were older than me
telling me to call them
to let us know what we were doing that
night because we were causing so much
[__] havoc
in my hometown the cops couldn't catch
up with us
nobody could catch up with us you know
i was telling people about the city how
much it's changed you know new york city
there was a house across the street from
the runnies
and i would sit there every day in 82
in the afternoons and lubes had come by
and the tabascos live next door and who
wasn't [__] walking home from high
school and who wasn't driving by to go
get weed at kurt's house or bonehead's
house that was the street where i lived
at so there was a ton of [__] action
and one day i'm looking at this house
i'm like this [__] only comes in
at night
that's it like he leaves at like six in
the morning i've never seen the guy
across the street
in the daytime but some nights when
we're sitting on the balcony like 10 10
30 i see him come home he's just a
regular white dude nice [__] car
and i was sitting and i'm like
i'm not doing right now maybe i should
burglarize this house
guys
i went behind that [__] house they
had like a little window to the
downstairs nobody could fit in that
[__] i was so skinny at the time
i fit in that [__] i popped the
window
and went down there i don't think there
was much money in the house
there was not much anything but i took
the phone
i took some blankets i took some albums
don't ask me why
but the most important thing i took out
of there was there was a
a nightstand
i couldn't open the nightstand
so
in my day when you couldn't [__] pop
a safe no problem just take it to go you
know what i'm saying and you could
[__] bring it to a
a safe guy who could torch it open or
you know you have a different
variety of ways with this [__]
nightstand i'm like what am i gonna do
with this [__] nightstand so i made
like two trips back and forth
across the street now one soul saw me
and then i carried over the nightstand
the nightstand was i don't know it
wasn't that heavy maybe it was
but it had a thick [__] piece of
glass
on the top like a big
piece of glass
maybe a little bigger than one of my
albums
so i didn't realize it till i brought
the [__] thing over we broke in it
there was maybe a couple hundred dollars
so a few naked pictures of him and his
wife i think not nothing i'm not gonna
what am i tommy lee's guy i'm gonna
blackmail him i didn't give a [__] i
didn't want to see him his wife naked or
him naked
so you know we did we kept the table we
kept everything else that i robbed we
had refurnished this little downstairs
apartment
mike ronnie had
so one that one night my friend's like
hey you want to go out and i'm yeah [__]
yeah we're going out tonight and like
you got to bring something to cut the
coke with and i go i got it so i brought
that glass up guys this glass
was an inch [__] thick
all the way around i mean it was heavy
it was a [__] heavy piece of glass so
i bring it with me
pelican fernie and my man glenn
and uh we would bring this glass with us
everywhere and let me tell you how
[__] crazy we were just so you guys
know
at night we would put coke on the glass
and put on the hood of the car
and sit outside the car and just talk
with people and people would walk by and
they would never see that [__] piece
of glass
with [__] coke on it they wouldn't
they would never see it and we would die
laughter
so one night when the amp parking lot
there was an amp shopping center across
the street from hudson county [__]
parking
and me and my buddies are sitting there
as four gorillas we got the the mirror
out on the [__] hood it's dark
so you really can't see us where we're
at there's lights in the parking lot but
we're sitting there's no
real lights you can tell we're there but
you can't see what's on the [__] hood
of the car so
we're sitting there going back and forth
blah blah whatever yelling listen to
music and all sudden we see a guy
walking and there was a ton of people
that night walking back and forth
we see a guy walking
he notices us so he comes walking over
to us hey how you guys doing
now we could have been douchebags we
could have told the guy get the [__] out
of here but now we're like hey how you
doing buddy
and he comes over nothing man
do i know you guys i'm just talking to
them you know we're looking at each
other like winking like let's [__] with
this guy so we start hey man you know
what's going on
after about 10 minutes the guy's
drinking he's getting comfortable
and i start him with with him i go
listen man i don't know if you guys know
this
you know don't judge us by the [__]
cover but we're all gay
and the guy's like you're gay what are
you talking about you're gay i'm like
we're gay
we like to swing brother are you into
swinger
and he's like i i don't think so huh
i'm not really into this [__] i'm like
what are you talking about
everybody [__] swings
you know you don't suck dick and i'm
like that the guy's like what are you
what are you guys talking about like
listen we're dick suckers
professional
we're 18 years old man the guy that i
don't know the guy's maybe 24. he's
looking at us all weird and [__] like
what are you guys talking about like
listen
we're professional dick suckers as a
matter of fact
and i think i'm i speak for all of us
we want to suck your dick
and the guy's like
really i'm like all of us
will suck your dick we'll stick fingers
in your ass we'll light your balls on
fire we'll suck your dick with an ice
cube whatever you want
[__] you'll get your [__] your
wish is our command
and this guy starts looking at us
he's looking at this weird awesome this
guy something goes in his head he just
starts running
he goes [__] you and he just starts
running and he's like [__] you
[__] [__] i can't believe
him as he's running with our luck
we're [__] starting to laugh and all
of a sudden we see a cop car go by
this [__] guy starts chasing the cop
car yo yo
i'm getting attacked by a bunch of
[__] you know you gotta help me we're
not even chasing the [__] guy we're
in the back laughing but we're not
laughing now
we're not this cop's not going to stop
sure enough the cop stops
gets out of the car
puts a flashlight in this guy's face and
he's going off those guys over there
they want to suck my dick you got to go
over and talk to them and [__] we're
like oh [__]
we thought the cop wasn't going to turn
around sure enough the [__] cop may
say you turned
and heads into that [__] amp parking
lot
i'm like [__] so my buddy roger got
rested so
he doesn't know what to do he gets in
the car
and he [__] takes off and we're like
roger
roger we can't say the coke is on the
hood and we're like the hood the hood
and he's looking at us going what and
finally we go the
hood and he goes what and he [__]
steps on the brake and the glass
slides right off the front of his
[__] car and it smashes onto the
concrete now remember there's no cars in
this parking lot usually takes 75 80
cars
it's the size it's half the size of a
football field
and we're trapped in between like trees
uh a haircut in place or whatever the
[__] is there and the amp wall so
there's a big thing when this [__]
glass
hits the
the concrete it just goes
bam like a shotgun went off you just see
like boom and we're like oh no now the
cop is [__] really looking around the
little gay guy is running towards us you
guys are going to go to jail and all
this [__] [__] you that's what you get
for being gay and we're like oh my god
this could not i go roger get the [__]
out of the car and drive over the glass
just drive over you're not gonna get a
flat tire he goes okay
finally the cop comes back there
he [__] reads the
the [__] uh you know the bumper
whatever the numbers are on the bumper i
don't know if he wrote him down or
called him into the station or whatever
the [__] he was doing
he puts his hat on he gets out of the
car he's not a north bergen cop or a
jersey city cop or union city cop or
west new york cop this [__] is a
hudson county police cop
they're in charge of the park
uh
yeah basically they're in charge of the
parks and i don't know what else what
that jurisdiction is
this guy gets out
walks over to us and he's like what the
[__] is going on
can somebody please tell me like officer
nothing
you know he goes i'm hearing booms
i'm hearing [__] i'm seeing cars and
now i got this net wit
telling me you guys want to rape them
and all this [__] is this true like rape
nobody said nothing about rape
we were just busting his balls we were
having a couple beers officer and he
came home and started you know [__]
talk to us about being gay or whatever
he's like listen
i don't care who's gay
i don't care who's not gay
i don't need this
the guy's telling us this is because i i
don't need this at all
i'm like what are you talking about he's
like i don't need this i'm off in 15
minutes
if i got to arrest him or you guys
that means i got two hours of [__]
paperwork and i'm gonna be pissed off
and i'm gonna break all your [__]
heads
so do me a favor stop busting this guy's
balls
if you want wait till i leave wait about
20 minutes take him in the park and kill
him i don't give a [__] what you doing
this is what a cop is telling us and
we're like what and he's like i don't
want you doing this out here or in my
jurisdiction while i'm on [__] duty
he goes tomorrow i'll come on at nine
o'clock whatever time he came on and he
goes i see it in the report that you
guys took him in the park and stabbed
him but don't do it when i'm a [__]
on duty and will i
and the guy is running to us going
arrest him arrest him throw him in
[__] jail and we're like we're not
going to jail [__] we're giving
you five minutes to start running and
we're gonna hunt you down that [__]
park the guy jumped the fence went to
hudson county park and we never [__]
saw that guy again that's what we were
doing to people by i mean we were
[__]
dying of laughter another night we were
at pathmark getting beer because we were
too young to buy beer so we'd have to go
to and hang outside supermarkets and
trade people like a [__] uh a joint
and there was no blunts back then or
nothing nobody was smoking blunts back
then in 82. we have to give people
[__] be you know a dollar or ten
dollars or a joint or two joints or a
nickel bag to go on and get us cocktails
what time we're hanging out in front of
[__] pack mark i don't know if you
can a lot of you guys don't remember
this but one of the first podcast guests
i had was a kid by the name of danny
calandrillo [__] all-state
all-american led the country in scoring
when he was like a sophomore at seton
hall look it up if you want dan
calendrillo came from a real complex
family
they were like nine or ten of them i
don't know exactly what the count was
but he had a sister that i knew that was
really cute that worked at the high
school
and he also had a brother
that his name was paul land he was in
spring break and the movie the idol
maker if you guys want to check it out
i mean he kind of inspired me
to be honest with you it was paul land
who let me know that
maybe i'd go to hollywood and do
something with my life i wasn't sure i
mean he didn't pull me aside and tell me
this but from me talking with him and
playing basketball with him and his
brother
i would always ask him creepy questions
about how did you get the movie
you know
and he would tell me but i didn't know
where the [__] he was coming from you
know i'm not gonna lie to you i didn't
know what a casting director was i
didn't know what a [__] agent was or
whatever
but he was a good guy and uh
i could see you know
again he made me at least he gave me
hope that
somebody from hudson county
you know i had him i had michael corin i
had sinatra
you know i had a couple of nice
influences but it was paul land really
since i knew him and i spoke to him
his name was kalandrillo when he got to
hollywood i guess he changed it to land
calendrillo is too hard to remember and
uh
but
i don't even know what the [__] we're
talking about oh so we're talking about
this [__] uh
you know north bergen and
and uh
what we were doing our [__] senior
year you know
but without it [__] pathmark and
we had just gotten some booze and was
sitting out there minding our own
business
one of the other brothers calendrilo had
was a guy who was homeless he had uh
mental health issues which i found out
later in 1982 when you saw somebody who
was homeless you just thought they were
crazy
it wasn't even called mental health
issues you thought he was crazy
you thought he was a bum whatever i
always gave
uh bobby cal a couple bucks when i saw
him you know when i was a kid he would
always ask me for a cigarette or a joint
i didn't smoke but i'd buy him a pack of
cigarettes because his brother
well paul land gave me hope and danny
was a great basketball player he was
always good to us he's a teacher back at
the high school now
i was thinking of going up there and
seeing when i had some time and thanking
him for what he did for me one way he
called the podcast in the beginning and
it was a great conversation but
after that i tried to contact him and i
think danny was a little mad at me
because i told the story
on the podcast weeks later about his
brother we were
at patchmark
having a great time now bobby cal would
always show up
when you least expect it like you could
be at the [__] hudson county park and
olsen you would hear like
and that means he's [__] walking
towards you because he had like a limp
and he would drag the other foot in the
leaves do you hear it in my
impersonation
so he's dragging lee's with the bum leg
he would always you know we talked on
bobby cow what's going on we would give
him a beer smoke some pot with him give
him a few joints so i wasn't his enemy
or anything
this one day we're at [__] path mark
on tunneling avenue down there on 76th
street reminding our business
we're on the side because they used to
be a thing called liquemart and uh and
pathmark liquemart was [__] huge i
think it's still there i don't know if
it's called lickmart but liquemart was
huge that case would be i tried to get a
job there once they wouldn't hire me
they knew i had sticky fingers so
[__] uh i'm outside talking to bobby
cow it's me stinky ferns
pelican and we're just talking to him
like
and all of a sudden one of the guys
looks at me he's like you know it gives
me the look let's start torturing this
[__] what are we doing
just hanging out here so we start
talking to him bobby kyle you suck dick
he's like nah nah nah i don't do that
[__] we keep busting these balls like
bobby you taking the ass now why are you
guys bringing this at me
inquiring minds want to know brother you
know we're just we're just going back
and forth
and one thing leads to another and i see
a newspaper on the floor like just uh
like a section like you know newspaper
has sections
this one had like sections
i wrap up the [__] newspaper
and without him seeing me i put in his
back pocket now he's got a he's got
overalls on he's got like he's living in
the park he's got his costume on and
then on top of that he's got like
overalls on like mechanic overalls
so we put it in his pockets a little
bigger i put the piece of paper in his
pocket
and after about three minutes of talking
to him i slept behind him
real softly before he could even see me
and i i light the piece of paper on fire
now he's talking to us the way i'm
talking to this camera
and it's like you know we're all like
one two three four they're talking i'm
bobby cow and all of a sudden you could
see the smoke
starting to come over his right shoulder
and we're [__] dying like this this
is not happening he's sending smoke
signals over his right shoulder and then
with that
the next move was you could see flames
every couple minutes that was not good
but he couldn't feel the flames because
he had the overalls on do you understand
me so it was already burning into the
overalls he just couldn't [__] feel
it and listen guys
i'm 58 i knew i was [__] up but when
you're [__] 18
it's just another day of a joke a lot of
people are going to watch this and go
what the [__] joey you're lighting
people on fires too no we were kids
we were joking around this is all part
of growing up
and all of a sudden we see like every
two minutes
you see a little flame pop up and she
will like when this is egg gonna catch
on fire and finally we're about to tell
bobby cow bobby you're on fire and he's
like what the [__] is going on why do i
smell fire and he turns around he keeps
turning but the paper is now dropping
pieces of fire on the floor so there
probably has to be like [__]
six little fires going on around them
and uh
he's like who the [__] let me on fire or
whatever and he turns back and his
[__] sleeve is going up on fire and
we tackle him to the floor and we gotta
hit him with like a half a beer and we
gotta like somebody took off this shirt
and we had to put him off in flames and
i'll never forget that he's like should
i call the police i'm like nah
what are you gonna call the police for
bobby somebody threw a match at you as
they were driving by i mean he didn't
even know it was us
but i still remember talking to him for
a couple of minutes and smoke was just
coming out of his clothes like the
inspector caluso and [__] return of
the pink panther the reason why i
remembered it was on the r9 and i saw
him when he's smoking he says you know
you gotta have balls he had the [__]
underneath but that's not important that
was the name of the costumer balls the
great balls
so we let this [__] on fire we
put him out and that was
we're sitting there talking to him as
he's like who would put me on fire and
you could see smoke coming from his
[__] outfit like
we don't know but that was just that was
every time we went out
and this [__] would get out you know
this [__] would just get out and people
go tell me they didn't like buy and this
is way before i let the bum on fire on
shredder behind ralphie may's house this
is [__] a long time ago but all these
things like now listen nobody brings
them up
only the kids that i grew up with like
when i seen glenn last time we talked
about a couple things and we were
[__] dying
listen we were young
um
[Music]
we were stupid
but one thing i do not apologize back
then is
that we had the biggest balls of [__]
life when i think about some of the [__]
we were doing at that age
oh my god
just oh my god you know i look at mercy
i'm like she's [__] nine
she's nine years away
from doing
i remember years ago i was in seattle
and
i was at this guy who was a nice guy not
the funniest comic in the world
but a great guy i
listen i never even really liked the guy
but now in hindsight thinking about it
this conversation
you know bothers me because i think
about him
we went to do a gig together and i was
talking about
you know how life was in jersey he's
from indiana this guy
and i was talking about how life was in
jersey when we were growing up that you
know business owners would make payoffs
and you know we were just having a
little talk
but i guess
the next night at the comedy club when i
got back
he wanted to be a wise ass in front of
people and like wanted to throw it in my
face
i think it was me him and josh wolf in
the car and we were trying to explain
you know payoffs and
boston and just police [__] just talking
about you know
nonsense about like uh you know
we were talking he was saying that
he snapped at one point he's like i
can't keep listening to this
this is not the way americans live you
know
most people don't make payoffs to the
police most people
are decent people like [__] you it's
like i felt like harvey i felt like
rodney
rodney dangerfield and uh back to school
when you're sitting there you're
experienced as a man and this teacher's
telling you you know what are you going
to do about cool yeah i mean rodney was
like a millionaire for business and he's
taking a business course if you've never
seen the movie in high school in college
he's taking a business course in college
and this guy's telling him about all his
costs and [__] and this guy's like what
are you talking about
what about the mafia they control
[__] but people who are
straight-laced don't understand that
world and they don't want to know what
beliefs that's what happens today with
people they don't want to know what
believes or it exists or they want to
put it down but he said something that
actually hurt my feelings in a way he's
like i don't understand where you people
come from it's all a bunch of criminals
this is what listen guys it's not that
we're criminals nothing with pieces of
[__]
it's not that i don't pay all [__]
cops when was the last time he heard me
paying off cops
what we did as young kids or followers
forever
there's nothing you could do
to shake it whether you broke a window
whether you robbed the [__] hubcap
from somebody it's done
there's nothing
you could do
to [__] change that you could just
become a better [__] person that's
all you could do i mean i would
it's not that we were bad people
you know i was never a [__] thief
before i moved to jersey okay i'm not
blaming my thievery on new jersey but
i'm saying that when i was a kid i was
such a little [__] catholic
the only thing i took was a couple
quarters from my mother at the bar and
doug i remember these quarters because i
felt [__] guilty about them when
you're a cuban kid your mother tells you
if you steal from your mother or you
raise your hand to your mother when
you're in the casket when you die your
hand pops up at the [__]
funeral when you're now at 58 i don't
give a [__] if my hand pops up i'm dead
what do i give a [__] what are they
gonna have opinion on me he robbed from
his mother he no
that [__] doesn't even [__] happen i
mean it does happen if they don't pull
enough for a mild hiding and all that
[__] after two or three days body parts
start [__] moving and they're not
just going to bend your leg and put in
the casket they actually got to break
your [__] kneecap i forget what it's
called rigor mortis correct bring them
all this sets in
so
as a child i never even thought of
[__] taking nothing i really never
did i
i mean as a kid we took fruit from a
fruit sand
but i never i would go home and feel
[__] terrible for weeks it wasn't
until i got to jersey that
you know we started out with stealing
punks again
punks are not anybody's property
punks are in the swamps you know what
punk town mike when you you steal them
and you light them on fire keeps the
mosquitoes away well that's what they
say who the [__] knows but
that's what
we were doing and then
yeah we went on to the trains again it
wasn't a friend of ours
you know i never really [__] thought
about it
it was until my mother died
and
i was angry at the world and i wanted to
take it out in the world
so i [__] robbed i started stealing
but before my mother died that wasn't
even in my world and just to let you
know that i'm not a [__] thief yeah
i haven't stole a lighter from a
7-eleven in maybe
10 years because they don't give you the
opportunity anymore they don't put them
out in the front anymore but if they
still put the lighters out i would
probably shop with the lighter once a
year
just to check in with my old self like i
always said you got to check in on your
skeletons in the closet before they
[__] check in on you so
but i'm not a [__] thief if if i was
still stealing then you would have gone
joey's a [__] stone cold thief
i stole because it was my way of getting
back at the world
when you're a kid and they break your
[__] belief system
that's all i had and uh
thinking back i mean i [__] hate it
when i was a thief
there's friends that i have back here
that i can't touch in with them or
anything because
in some way
directly or indirectly
my thievery affected them whether it was
a friend a neighbor themselves you know
i really regret that i can't regret
selling drugs you can't take the [__]
drugs back i can't regret
have to [__] you know i could regret
half the [__] i did
the stealing part guys there's nothing i
could do about it yeah i can repay to
people or make amends with them or
whatever you ever try making amends with
somebody you rob from didn't want to
talk to you and especially when it was
so [__] long ago so
you know and that's
what the story we're getting to is at
the end i mean i think of all these
things i did
when i should have just been paying
attention and doing homework we were out
we were already
men the three guys i hung out with yeah
they were in high school but we were men
they weren't getting no money from their
mothers or anything their parents were
working steps
you know we were getting money
we were paying without for our drugs
without our drug habit with the money we
were stealing or better yet
i was uh
stealing and would use them
to be my lookouts or whatever and i'm
not proud of that either none of those
three kids were thieves never wanted to
be kids they were all [__] hard
workers so
my stealing influenced a lot of people
in the wrong way
like i said i've lost a lot of friends
because of it
especially here in jersey
from my uh
childhood [__] but at the same time
stealing is bad as stealing is good but
sometimes you gotta catch a break from
time to time
to let you know you're gonna be all
right
i always think about how
i was always
scared
i was always scared of going to jail i
was always scared of getting arrested
you know i look at my daughter
and my daughter's biggest fear in the
world is going to the principal's office
that's her biggest fear in the world
if my daughter got sent to the
principal's office
she would have a nervous breakdown
because in her eyes it means the worst
person in the world it's my daughter
she's [__] nine she's a kid she
doesn't know better but for me
i think the worst thing in the world
the worst feeling in the world was not
when i was a kid i hadn't caught a break
since 1979 since my mother died again
i'm not feeling sorry for myself i'm not
saying anything in a weird way but
i didn't catch a break for years
1982 was the first time
before my mother died i was really
making
uh strides or meeting people
i was popular and [__] then
i became popular for my mother dying and
that's a horrible thing to have when
you're in deep conversation with
somebody and somebody tells you that
they had a talk with michael and they
were at michael's house eating and
michael's parents are saying how they
felt bad for me and my mother died i
[__] hated that
i [__] hated the feeling that people
felt bad for me
because my mother died so what i did was
i wanted to start a neutral i wanted
i didn't want people to be [__] uh
sad for me
i wanted people and i was alive
so
at the end of 82 not even the end the
end of the summer of 82
that summer i mean the word was getting
out yeah
you know coco robs drug dealers he
steals
whatever from time to time
but
[Music]
in 1982 you know i love draftkings
i was talking to somebody about this i
think jimmy at the gym the thing i like
about draftkings is you really can't get
in trouble with gambling unless you're a
[__] [__]
draftking when i call mike if mike is my
bookie i'll call mike
on a monday no mike i want to bet the
knicks tonight and michael okay what's
the line how much you want to bet on
them the line is seven i think last
night
uh whatever the [__] the mormons
what's the what's the
what's the where do mormons play wise
guys utah jazz were playing the next
last night they were giving them seven
points what if i liked utah last night
what if i was making 200 a week as an
electrician's helper and i call mike
this weekend is valentine's day weekend
i want to take my girlfriend i'm going
to get my dick sucked i want to take her
out for dinner i want to have a grandma
blowing you know what we think about it
why don't we get a limousine for a buck
50 even though i only make 200 a week so
i decide to call my cop and bet heavy
with mike all [__] week
i bet have you with mike all week the
first time i lose
and 110 bucks i lose the game and the
ten dollar vig
that means tuesday i gotta catch up
again so i'll put a fifty dollar bet in
so i could get it down to fifty five
bucks but guess what
it loses that night
so now i'm down one [__]
165.
so wednesday i call in for another
hundred thursday for another hundred now
i got myself down 400 something dollars
doesn't look like mike's getting this
doe
i'm in trouble i overextended myself i
went over my head with draftkings they
won't take
they only take money straight from a
bank account
so if you put 500 in your books or 300
in your books or 200 in your books
that's that's it after that's gone yeah
you could go again but they won't let
you take a cash advance or a draw
you follow me like a visa draw like uh
if you take
500 bucks from visa
wait you get your bill the next month
for that cash advance
interest so
they don't take that
when i was a kid and even now i mean
listen new york city made
1.2 billion dollars in the last month in
gambling
i think 80 percent of people who signed
up for betting sites
never even placed a bed in before that's
how crazy gambling is going to [__]
blow up but my point is
the reason why i like these websites is
because you can't bet over your head you
can't
you can't you can put some bets and lose
and move the [__] on but you can't bet
over your head when i was a kid i used
to bet over my head all the [__] time
so now you're down five six hundred
dollars what do you do i either gotta
borrow the money from him he's gonna
juice me at three points a week or i'm
gonna [__] have to borrow money from
a relative which i didn't have and
what's behind door number three what's
your other option to hide
just duck him until he [__] moves the
[__] on
i did that for years when i was a kid
especially in high school
but in september of 1882 i put a bed in
with somebody i couldn't duck my high
school teacher
he's long he's long gone now he wouldn't
take any of my bets while he was our
teacher but once my friends graduated
and i was officially out of school
he started taking my bets me and my
buddy put a 2500 bedding with him
25 2500
that means we had to come up with like
when the bet turned in you know how much
money we had we didn't have 27
so for years i had
for like two or three years
whenever i was showing on money i go to
a jewelry store on burger line avenue
and lift a few things sometimes i lift a
few rings
sometimes i lift a few tray of [__]
rings it was tremendous you know i had
it down and i always said to myself if i
ever paint myself into a wall
i'm going to take the whole [__] cart
of gold chains it was just a [__] 100
gold chains and 100 bracelets i was so
stupid
i actually ended up doing it
40 years ago this september 15th
or september 23rd it'll be 40 [__]
years from now and my point i'm trying
to make to you guys is no
i wasn't cool because i robbed the joint
it didn't make me a better person
when the word got out that i had robbed
it it was the first time even though it
was something negative
did i tell you something a lot of people
were proud of in north bergen because
we're [__] new jersey's based on a
robbery system
but i got to be honest as warped as my
brain was at that time
i was leaving a little proud of myself
because
i had people talking about it
people coming up to me knowing what the
[__] and now
it was like
i was known as a thief
and i really
i really wasn't proud of that but it was
a lot better than being known
for a kid that i really felt sorry for
for his mother dying i don't know if you
even understand that logic
but that's what my head was at that
[__] age you know so
yeah then after that i had to leave the
cops looking for me they didn't press
charges everything worked itself out
and i learned a valuable lesson but
that's what that whole thing was about
then it wasn't about me being a [__]
thief or
you know it was about me
not wanting people to feel sorry for me
losing my mother i had nothing to do
with the animal that i was and once
people found out that i robbed that
jewelry store nobody felt sorry for me
that i lost my mother they could tell i
was just doing just fine
and that's the [__] podcast for this
week man
you know i uh
like i said a lot of people hit me up
this weekend
for the support for joe whatever listen
guys
joe always have my support to the end of
time he's done more for me
than any agent any comic any friend in a
long [__] time and you know what i
still have people who would stop talking
to me since i moved to l.a
and don't even call to say hello i gotta
tell you something about joe rogan he's
more my friend now that i've gotten out
of comedy he's more my brother so if you
have people that are on the [__] uh
fence about him or any of the things he
said i know how you guys feel about me
and
you know where i stand and all this you
know the type of person i am
listen he's a good man he's my brother
he's done a lot to help me i've done a
lot to help him and we work off each
other
and uh
hopefully i could be down there pretty
soon to do the podcast and
show you [__] we're still a
[__] team made in goddamn evan i'm
happy that i have him in my corner
i'm happy that he throws praises at me
and i'm happy that i could call him a
friend
the same way i called ari a friend the
same way i call red band a friend my man
mike a friend
listen when you have a friend you go
down to the end with that person whether
they're wrong or right
in this sense
rogan
is not right for what he said
but i don't want you guys to think
another negative light on him for
everybody's saying about him as a matter
of fact
[__] it he's my brother i love you
[__] with all my heart remember
white truffle is in
rainbow rutz is in
you know coco is in i just gave mike
half to batch the old batch and the new
batch so you could [__] try before
and after you know what i'm saying so if
he puts up a picture a before after and
way [__] after
don't be [__] surprised i'm
happy you tuned in this week
uh
we're getting better and [__] better
i'm feeling better and better
and we're getting healthier so uh we'll
be rocking please i hope you watch the
the [__] podcast
with my girl uh kim condom and uh
and sarah weinstrack she's [__]
they're pisses they're really cute and i
had a great time with them hopefully
this week i'd get back on sicklers or
somebody else's but until then i love
you [__] with all my heart
enjoy the [__] super bowl
don't go over your head
when the soup bowl ends please don't
beat your girl from your wife don't
become a statistic [__] and have a
great weekend have a happy valentine's
day i'll be back next monday on
[__] valentine's day stay black
have a great weekend and i love your
[__] with all my heart
all right i want to thank you savages
for listening to uncle joey's joint do
not forget the joint is brought to you
by on it when it comes to supplement
supplements plural on it is number one
in my [__] book and they're number
one with the country they're tremendous
company whether it's the black label
alpha brain
whether it's the shroom tech immune the
mct oil on it has something for you just
go to honor.com right now and look at
the finalists the supplements
kettlebells club bats mace
they have online working out
listen honor is a force to be reckoned
with but listen enough for bullshitting
go to honor.com read
you know what you don't you never worked
it on it before get yourself some alpha
brain give it a 30 day shot give it a 60
day shot tell me you're not sharper tell
me you thought your thoughts are not
clear and your dreams are clear to you
on it works and if you don't like alpha
brain they'll give you a money-back
guarantee who's better than you go to
honor.com and press in joey joint
or church
and get a 20 discount delivered right to
your [__] house the joint is
also brought to you by my favorite
c b d lion
bringing you the best cbd available how
do i know because i'm an old man i'm
falling apart and this cbd is keeping my
ass together that's how i know you're
gonna go to a liquor store and get it
from some [__] mooc
without a [__] education no i don't
have an education but i got street
education i'm telling you right now cbd
works whether it's cbd cbn cby
go to cbd line read the third party lab
results and then get back to me if you
see something you like order it pressing
code joey
and get 20 off delivered right to your
house and from the heart of new jersey
why keep breaking your balls
it's draft kings this is
the last season of nfl football let's
make a little money together
draftkings is the official sports
betting partner of super bowl 56 they're
tremendous and the official sports
betting pawn of the nfl
this week they're going to give you 56
to 1 odds on either team that means if
you bet 5 you're going to get 280 who's
better than you
it's either cincinnati or the rams it's
that easy this weekend you got the over
and under and you got prop bets but if
nfl is not for you
mma is more your style let me tell you
something ufc 271 live from houston
[__] tremendous card izzy against the
australian my man the beast against
[__]
tata tupa whether he's gonna drink out
of his [__] shoe listen download the
draftking sportsbook app it's the last
weekend to make some money with the nfl
even if you bet ten dollars it's more
than you got a chance to win you're not
gonna win unless you play
download the app use promo code joey
okay a draftking sports book now you got
to be 21 older minimum age is 20 min and
location requirements vary by
jurisdictions see draftkings
dot com sport book for full list of
requirements and state specific
responsible gaming resources it's easy
voidware prohibited now if you've got a
gambling problem call 1-800 gambler
if you're in tennessee 1-800-889-9789
if you're in connecticut 888-789-7777
hope new york or text new york but
anyway
it's draftkings i want to thank
draftkings i want to thank cbd lion i
want to thank annette
i want to thank bluechu
and i want to thank
you guys for [__] taking time
to download us listen to us and
supporting the podcast i love you
[__] with all my heart don't
forget laughing gas is available at the
ice cream shop i love you [__]
stay black and the ice cream shop is
having a party this friday night
at uh crazy girls on la brea stop in
tell them i sent you have a great
weekend
[Music]
so
you